mon classeur de factures et donc bah
voila j'ai assez de voiliers mais qui
est 650
après j'ai en dessous en fait j'ai ma
cotisation edf où je paye 115 euros par
mois et puis après j'ai d'autres
factures également bien sûr au téléphone
mutuelle assurance auto les factures
continuent de tomber chez malgré
l'installation du confinement
céline gestionnaire dans un centre de
formation de secourisme a été placés au
chômage partiel
elle a perdu un tiers de son salaire
avec désormais 1000 euros de revenus
mensuels
elle se demande si elle va bien pouvoir
payer sa plus grande dépense à savoir
son loyer de 650 euros
si on touche pas de salaire on peut pas
payer toutes les charges et après on se
retrouve en seul en endettement alors
que c'est pas de notre fait à
l'incitation ça sera des comme ce que
les gens vivent déjà pour certains c'est
de plus avoir assez d'argent
tout simplement pour voitures et toutes
les charges ce cas il faut payer toutes
les charges qui sont très importantes et
il ya encore une fois ce que je pense
c'est que on demande des efforts à tout
le monde et donc c'est passé ça serait
logique qu'ils que bah voilà puis un
suspension des loyers pendant la période
du confinement et même à la limite au
delà le temps que ledit une reprise de
l'activité depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire et des voix s'élèvent pour
demander des mesures des deux locataires
l'association droit au logement invite
l'état à s'inspirer de ses voisins et à
mettre en place un moratoire sur les
loyers chômage partiel loyer partiel 0
revenu 0 loyer c'est ça qu'il faut
mettre en place aujourd'hui pour les
locataires parce que les gens sont
angoissés comment ils vont faire la fin
du mois il ya plein de pays qu'ont
compris des mesures enfin je veux dire
l'espagne suspend le paiement des loyers
pendant trois mois et met en place une
baisse des loyers une baisse de la dette
de 50 % d'office
l'allemagne également suspendre
l'obligation de payer un loyer et étals
de paiement des loyers sur deux ans
voilà on a un cercle de pays qu'ils
prennent des mesures
il y en a plein d'autres un dire qu'ils
prennent des mesures en direction des
locataires des habitants pour pas qu'ils
se retrouvent à la rue
maintenant il faut que le gouvernement
prenne une une loi qui institue un
moratoire des loyers sur les loyers sont
suspendus vous et où les loyers y sont
pas payés ne donnent pas lieu à des
sanctions contre les locataires d'une
part d'autre part la mise en place d'un
fonds de plusieurs milliards d'euros
l'institution des recherches économiques
et sociales estime que plus de deux
millions cinq cent mille ménages
connaissent actuellement des difficultés
pour payer leur loyer ou leur prêt
immobilier pour l'heure le gouvernement
ne prévoit ni suspension ni report du
paiement des loyers
les expulsions locatives sont justes
interdite jusqu'au 31 mai